des numéros d'équilibristes des animaux
sauvages des clowns toute la panoplie du
cirque à l'ancienne étaient réunis ce
dimanche 12 février à lille de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines
la compagnie zavatta composée d'une
trentaine de personnes propose un
spectacle de près de deux heures pour
séduire le public le responsable
fresneau douchez prend la température
pendant la représentation
pendant l'entracte je parle avec le
public parce que déjà on est là pour les
accueillir et le public qui fait partie
du cirque
car c'est grâce à eux qu'on vit mais
c'est aussi pour eux que le cirque
existe donc on doit se mettre en contact
depuis qu aussi bien les petits que les
grands et les écouter puis chaque année
suivant ce qui plaît au public et ben on
sait se diriger sur certains artistes
venaient du gros qu'on garde deux ans de
suite
parmi les numéros fin de cette nouvelle
saison la femme laser une performance de
5 minutes avec des effets visuels on
pensait pas que ça allait faire aussi
bien aux adultes qu'aux enfants comme ça
alors que c'est simplement parce que tu
as trouverait plus dans les discothèques
que vous des cabaret et que l'assassin
mais au goût du jour et qui s'inscrit
dans le thème du ciel ça grand plaisir
devant le cercle ça va pas donc c'est
une grande famille de cirque et que
j'aime bien aller aussi à mes préférés
comme les chevaux au galop paul dano
honte et c'est un vrai
divertissement pour nom les adultes et
pour les enfants aussi moi je trouve que
ce c'est magnifique français ça nous
fait une sortie le cirque zavatta
restaurant résidence à saint quentin en
yvelines jusqu'à ce mercredi 15 février
avant de démonter son chapiteau pour
partir à dreux